[Music]
good morning everybody how you doing
welcome welcome welcome so much to this
dream thank you all so much for joining
me and I've got a lot of stuff to cover
as the title suggests we're going to
look at Wilfred wharfs - Wilfred
mother-loving wharfs - I apologize and
we were going to break down the entirety
of the production of that video and
we're gonna talk about some general life
stuff to catch up but before we do that
we're gonna let people filter into the
stream a little bit and then I'm going
to cover some little housekeeping things
that I have on my list over here and
then we're going to get into the main
brunch of it it's going to go I'm gonna
go through my list I've only got three
things so it's not very long and then
we're gonna watch through the video
Wilfred mother-loving more stuff we're
actually gonna watch it together but
it's gonna be a lot of stopping and
starting I'm gonna bring up production
pictures as it's necessary and then
we're going to basically just have some
fun
watch it commentate on it I'm gonna
reveal a bit of my my thoughts behind
the story of it there's been a lot of
very good like theorizing about it a few
people actually have nearly nailed it on
the head of what I wanted and I think
that's good because what I was going for
in this one was just I wanted it to be
less complicated and I think that's in
its nature like it's just overall
generally less complicated so I was
actually of the mind that I didn't even
want to say very much because people
were getting it people were
understanding it and people were also
understanding the other ancillary
feature which is like they'll look into
it too deeply but other than that yeah
I'm wearing glasses today so how you
guys doing yes this is this is
absolutely live it is 100% live can
basically markiplier reacts to his own
video pretty much we've done this for
the past few ones this one I'm just
doing it by myself because I was I guess
kind of the sole creative push behind
this Amy had a great deal of inspiration
for it but she is busy with other stuff
as you'll explain why she has to go get
her phone fixed and that's my fault
partially but she has to go get her
phone fixed in and
I just wanted to sit down and kind of go
through this with you guys as we go
through like we did with who killed
markiplier and like we did a date with
markiplier and also talked about other
things so hello hi where am I at I'm
home right now but I haven't been home
which is another thing that I'm going to
talk about in in the beginning of this
I'm gonna get I'm just gonna spend like
30 minutes to go through like the life
stuff and the general catch up of other
things then we're gonna get into the
main brunt of it yeah I've had these
glasses for a bit I just don't wear them
very often I've been doing context for
the most part and then um yeah I just
first well I let me explain something I
flew in this morning I have not slept
actually I was in I was in Hawaii
recently for a vacation that's second on
my list so I'll get I'll get to that in
a bit
first and foremost number one I wanted
to mention this before anything else
some of you may have seen the community
posts that I made and some of you have
may have seen Tyler's video that he
posted on his channel it's actually the
first video he's ever posted and kind of
like kicking off a few a few videos that
he wants to make if you didn't know
Tyler's mom has cancer Tyler stone face
Tyler one-word Tyler Tyler my friend
Tyler so he posted a video talking about
it and talking about you know his
obviously love for his mother and and
what he plans to do with it and what he
plans to create and how he plans to
cherish the you know the moments he has
with his mom and so if you can go find
the community post you can find it in
youtube.com slash markiplier slash
community you can look for it right
there it should be the last thing I've
posted there or you can go over to this
channel just search up Apocalypto
underscore 12 on youtube it'll be the
only video that's on his channel so
check that out and it's not really much
that you can do to support other than
just you know looking forward to the
cool videos that he's going to make with
his mom so that was gonna be first and
foremost number two where have I been
yes flew there for power my hair is
extremely unbelievably floofy it's got a
lot of salt water in it I've been on
vacation I have I kind of went radio
silent after the sprint of getting
this video done wharfs - video done and
then everything that came before with
all the writing i've been doing the
planning they're getting things in
motion and the headache of just wanting
to do so much and having so little to
show for it
so i've been putting off this vacation
forever if you know me I don't take
vacations but I it to myself and to Amy
to go on a vacation so we went out to
Hawaii the place where I was born not
that I have any connection to it other
than that but we went out to Hawaii and
we stayed out there for this past week
and it was wonderful it was really
really honestly wonderful I don't do
well when I'm not working so of course I
was still working while I was over there
I actually wrote another video that's
probably the next one that I'm gonna do
I think I wrote the next project like
the Wilfred Worf sesh video that I'm
gonna do so this musics a little too
creepy for the my this music so creepy
give me something cheery no
here we go that's good yeah I don't know
I was so creepy about that yeah so I
took a break we went over in Hawaii and
we did just basically typical relaxing
things we didn't do much we chilled out
we hung out by the beach we went
ziplining which I actually have some
pictures those of you who know me know
that I'm very very afraid of the ocean
but I'm proud to say I'm proud to say
Here I am on the ocean in the middle of
nowhere I would not get in the ocean I
had the chance to go scuba diving and
snorkeling and I'm like I'm not good for
that I'm not good for that but I did go
on the ocean which was very nice every
time I'd fall off this is a paddleboard
every time I'd fall off it'd be
scrambling panic to try to get back on
the board
but you know it was it was fun because
we we got to have a lot of fun it was
nice to get some Sun you can see how
pasty I am here and I've actually got
some Sun so I'm I'm tan now and also
like while I was out there it was this
really really beautiful beach that we
were on you know you could really see
like the clear water and I was just
paddling along and this turtle just
popped up out of nowhere this turtle is
just here and just like I was I was able
to snap a picture of it oh also the
reason why amy has to go get her phone
fixes because I brought her to take some
pictures and fell in the ocean and I was
fine for a bit it was fine for a bit but
as of just like 12 hours ago when we
loaded onto the plane to come back here
it just shut off and didn't turn back on
so oops yeah that didn't it didn't go so
good but it was it was really fun so we
we did that and then we also went
ziplining which is really cool just like
Amy and I we went ziplining and we went
through this this one in pillow a
something like that this zip lining
place really cool place we had a ton of
fun with it like they have one of the
longest they have the longest zip
in Hawaii at a half a mile long like a
half a mile zip line and I've got a
video to show you guys let me let me
load it up real quick but it was it was
just super fun it was it was good times
I'll run I've never been ziplining
before it's probably to be loud let me
turn the volume down on this because
it's just like wind whipping as far as
the eye can see
so let's see I'm right about okay let me
turn the music off real quick and whoops
nope stop area all right so yeah I've
never been ziplining before and we just
it we just go ziplining and so you'll
see me grimacing because I I very
stupidly had my phone out and the wind
was catching it so I was squeezing as
hard as I could to try to keep a hold of
my phone I only recorded one of them
this was like the second of five lines
that we did and that's a starfish
maneuver to slow down and so yeah we did
that anyway so that was that was real
fun and then we went to we went to see
the island from a helicopter tour and
that was goddamn beautiful like words
can't describe what that helicopter tour
was like just being able to see
everything on the island see all like
the natural beauty of Hawaii but this
this picture of my face might so Amy Amy
snuck of this picture
Amy snuck this picture of me looking out
the window at just the [ __ ] beauty of
it like it was so unabashedly gorgeous
and I was just staring out the window
the entire time I was like oh my god
just look at the landscape there and
just to give you some perspective of
what we were looking at it's like again
picture does no justice to this but we
were up at about like 2003 a thousand
feet just looking down at these sheer
cliffs just huge cliffs and there were
waterfalls like tiny little strings of
waterfalls all throughout this entire
landscape just like it's
so unbelievably beautiful like just
ridiculously beautiful and we went out
on like just we were super lucky the day
we went out it was just the right amount
of clouds clear God it was beautiful so
it was a 1 it was a wonderful vacation
I'm really happy that it went but also
I'm really happy to be back and I'm
really happy to be back here where I can
make videos again because I know for a
fact that I have not been making videos
and that's been chewing me up inside to
be perfectly honest but thankfully
gritty sugar had that wonderful
animation we know the getting over in
animation was just goddamn amazing so
I'm back had a great time with vacation
and it was great - is this great to get
some brain like who's like get the brain
gunk out of my ears taken some like
nature I I hardly ever get out of the
house so going out of the house to
Hawaii and seeing like the beaches and
the sunsets in the landscape was just
like exactly what I needed and it's been
great so now now we get to do wouldn't
we need I'm wearing a backpack no it's
just a coat just got hood yeah it's a
little cold in here which is better than
the alternative of being hot in here so
next time I list someone asks has anyone
gotten the phone number yet the digits
thing okay so this has been another
headache of mine but thankfully it's not
been a headache for me it's been a
headache for the company doing it so
it's been overwhelming and they have
actually told me specifically to try to
minimal minimize the amount of texting
I've been putting out because the way
the system works is it collates numbers
and it sends out responses so that
people people can fill out contact
information and then I can have like a
phone book of people in my phone and
it's not so that they text me directly
and my phone blows up it's an
intermediary so that I can text people
one at a time or in groups or in bulk I
can text people by when it's your
birthday I can wish you happy birthday
like stuff like that I can text people
but state by state but the system has
just been crushed by you
so in all honesty it's your fault but
it's finally catching up now I'm very
happy to say and this is trust me
there's good news
there's only 91 thousand people left
waiting in line and that number has been
steadily going down people keep adding
into it and but it's been trending down
which is the first time it's been
trending down to completion so it's it's
it's going but it'll get there soon so
if you haven't gotten it yet
there's 91 thousand people left waiting
and that's like more people filter in
but that's trickling down slow so I have
not been able to send out text as much
as I want to but that's just because if
I send out text to everybody that just
means people wait longer so I've been
waiting for the system to catch up and
then we've been getting things in order
so that's on route all right so I think
that catches up everything that was
everything that was on my list how are
you guys doing you guys good yeah you
guys good it still doesn't work in
international yet because it doesn't
even work in America yet we haven't
gotten it fully fleshed out but it's
it's a really cool system and and we're
just like yeah we're just no it's just a
whole bunch of things that I'm really
excited for and it was like a lot of
that headache that got vented out when I
took a little bit of vacation and I
didn't want to take a vacation but I'm
glad I did love my hair why it is a mess
I literally walked off the beach
onto the plane and then came out here so
it's just this entire like smorgasbord
of sand and salt and everything else
that's left from Hawaii that I decided
to take with me year is I a dog I don't
know I don't know I'm not um percent
sure it would explain a lot of things
but yeah let's see am I gonna play in
the game today not on this live stream
this live stream is going to be now just
focused on analyzing Wilfred
mother-loving worse - I'm gonna show you
guys some behind the scenes stuff I'm
gonna show you guys some of the thought
process behind it and I'm gonna show you
guys like the other things that I have
in mind for and we're gonna walk through
it together and just kind of discuss it
and and I gotta say thank you guys so
much for being like so enthusiastically
responsive to
this video I I'm so happy that you guys
liked it so many of you liked it and
it's just it really does like warm my
heart because this project this one was
like the tester the first tester of
seeing if I could make these in a higher
production way while also being more
expedient about it like getting him out
in a more timely fashion because here's
some facts about the production like I
wrote the script in a day I sent it off
to the production company and then we
had to wait because various other life
things got in the way but once
production got rolling we found stuff it
was planned in a week we shot it in
three days and then I edited it in three
days so in all honesty it took about two
weeks to make that whole thing as nice
as it looked as well done as it was and
I'll show you some of the the cheats
that we made to make it work better but
as nice as it was and has done up as it
was like this was not that hard to make
the production company that I was
working with like really made life a lot
easier and it was a tester because with
the new sponsorship system or as it's
called now Channel memberships so the
sponsor button is now a join button but
with the funding from you guys to put
towards this video I wanted to see if it
was at all possible and it was and
that's the great news about it like it
was the system works it does work I know
enough to make it work the production
company I can trust enough to make work
and then when it all comes together
because like I wrote it and I was
directing it and I was able to like tell
people exactly what I needed because I
knew I was going to edit it it came
together really really well so moving
forward from that you guys can see a bit
more into the inside of it so let's turn
off the music and let's get into the
brunt of this so we're gonna start off
I'm gonna stop a lot because there's
going to be a lot of times when I'm just
going to pause it and I'm gonna pull up
some pictures and stuff and we're just
going to go through that so let's just
get into this
man this opening just love it's so much
I'm so happy
also this video was shot in 4k and I
uploaded it in 4k it's probably the
first the first video I've ever done in
4k so I'm stopping it here just to talk
about like this opening shot this was
not only the first shot of the video
this was the first shot of the entire
shoot like this was the moment when we
had no idea whether it was gonna work or
not because I'd never worked with this
production company before the director
of cinematography Dan I'd never worked
with him before so it was really like I
was just trying to translate what I was
what I wanted into the video itself and
I was like this has to be film noir this
is film noir this is dripping film noir
this is over enthusiastically cliched
film noir and that was very important
because of the detectives character
here's a here's a picture of of McKee
and I just like hanging out this is the
this the setting that it was like it
really was interesting because it
already had a cork board up here the
chalk board was already there Mick
basically wrote out a bunch of names at
will we didn't plan any of those names
he just wrote out names as will and like
filled out that chalk board we had a set
dresser kind of fill out the rest of it
and then I'm just here trying to pull up
like my script my notes music that I had
planned because I'd already picked out
the pieces of music one of the ways that
I like to work in terms of writing is
like when I write I like to get the
music in mind because the music really
sets the mood for what I want and it
really helps convey message on set
whenever I'm trying to explain things to
people that don't understand how the
final product that's the biggest
important thing about a production in
general if you're in a production or if
you're working with people to try to
make something happen like getting them
on the same page as you in your mind no
it is the most important thing possible
so once I was able to like get everyone
going and like kind of like give
everyone an idea of what I wanted it was
a lot easier to put out and so when it
came down to making like things work and
like here's just a an example of like
what we had going on like I was trying I
wasn't even in costume yet
and I was gonna be and it was so weird
because the first day of shooting like
we did the beginning and end of the
videos so we had to do the end of it
before we even really like got confident
about what we were doing so it's this
really nice camera over here I think it
was like an FS 7 I believe this is dan
dan was the man with all the photography
stuff this is Chris I don't know who
this is but I I know them but I can't
tell who this is behind their back but
so Dan would just like shout out we get
the lighting setup so quick and
efficient well done all across the board
and then once we found out that the
first shot was gonna work no oh that
yeah well I don't know why that's a
video but once we found out why the
first shot was gonna work when we could
see it on the monitor with like a test
LUT which is just a color correction
thing once we saw that we're like oh my
god this is gonna work all the beautiful
shots not that the the things that we've
done ourselves in the past have been
ugly but all the beautiful shots of like
movie level cinematography which is what
I wanted we're all dan dan and his team
like the the people lighting it like oh
he's just so quick and able to just
respond on-the-fly dan is the [ __ ]
man and that's not the same dan from the
tour that is a different Dan but anyway
so Dan is the man this is Dan Dan's the
man he is super good also Mick good god
Nick Nick is just an incredible actor
alright we're gonna carry on
so all in all I wanted it to drip with
film noir and that's very important just
because to him nothing else could be
I've never been much for smoking but
taking a bullet to the chest will make
you a lot less worried about the slow
deaths of the world long story short I
took a job I shouldn't have
they say the pretty ones will always get
you killed but he was so damn handsome I
just couldn't resist a little bit of
clarification there when he's referring
to taking a job from a pretty one like
the the one that's so damn handsome is
actor mark from who killed markiplier
he's not referring to Worf stash there
cuz he's Tate he took the job from actor
mark to do it and he's saying that so
just a little clarification I was a frog
in a slow pot of boiling water or the
first clown to get into the clown car
you don't know to get out until it's too
late I had so many more clown jokes in
my first script I had so many more clown
jokes in my first script that that just
didn't make the final cut so yeah
there's a deleted scene in this I'll
show you in a second that I didn't end
up using but just like I wanted this
running theme of clowns and then just
because it was like I thought it was
funny if just like because I was trying
to write in jokes like all this is just
jokes intermixed with normal film noir
like he's doing this speech that
everybody knows the film noir speech
though the the voice in the head just
like thinking out loud kind of just
talking about reality its exposition but
its exposition in such a stylistic way
there nobody minds that it's exposition
yeah one thing led to another and I
found myself slow dancing with the devil
in the moonlight except instead of
leaving room for Jesus he left room for
a 357 Magnum and you'll find like in
this dialogue he's saying over and over
like the events of who killed markiplier
that's basically all he's talking about
here it's I put this here because I
wanted this to be able to exist as a
standalone thing where if someone was
watching this and didn't watch hukum
Marc Blair they would still know what's
that's basically won't bore you with the
details so I'll cut right to the quick a
lot of people died because of this man
William J damn it come on William J
Barnum aka the colonel
okay little thing about this not planned
in any way shape or form not plan not
planned at all we meant for it to go
right in the first time it was so damn
funny like because it just like it was
piddly little like thing and and like I
put that in the first promo I put out
but in the first promo you can hear us
laughing just off the screen just
laughing super hard because we just
didn't expect and then it happened again
like Mick was really trying to just like
show his hand acting like his goddamn
hand acting was so good so his third try
so that was just something like like we
just made it work like we made it work
we didn't plan that in any way just
happened to go that way so yeah just
like the clown my bar mitzvah clown knew
he was trouble from the moment I laid
eyes and just like bozo the Magnificent
a lot of people died when he walked into
my life I've been chasing him down ever
since we were like two naked men running
on the same treadmill okay so one thing
I want to point out that is often
overlooked amazingly overlooked in a lot
of the theory stuff I had he's got a
vape there's a joke he's got a [ __ ]
vape he's got vapes through the whole
video he's got lots of vapes like it's
it's funny it is funny but also like
this was intentionally written in the
the reason being is like that that
doesn't belong in film noir time what's
that there oh well anyway and even him
like just just giving it like that
slight glances like Nick just like he
looks at it doesn't see anything weird
with it no that's fine yeah
that's important but no one can run
forever
especially not with 200 pounds of sweaty
detective breathing down your neck it
hasn't been easy though and I can't
count how many countries I've cornered
him in couldn't tell you how many times
I've had him in my big strong hands
every time I think I've got him for good
he somehow manages to slip away okay so
I wanted to write in early like clues
that Nick kind of understands what's
going on but doesn't know specifics of
it like the concept of he says and I
wrote very specifically like couldn't
tell you how many countries couldn't
tell you how many times I've had him in
my big strong hands he's he's saying
that and that's a phrase but also he
can't tell you how many times he's out
him in his big strong hands
he's just saying that because like
that's what's expected like to be sound
how many countries I've cornered him in
can't count how many countries I've
cornered it in can't can't count unable
to couldn't tell you how many times I've
had a strong so didn't tell you any time
I think I've got him for good he somehow
manages to slip away John now but he's
running out of holes to hide in I mean
that literally metaphorically and
euphemistically it doesn't matter how
crafty you think you are if you've been
on the run for years and years
you're gonna make a mistake all right so
that was pretty much the the opening
chunk the first first half of the first
day of filming was just filming that
like figuring it out and one of the
things that I loved about like doing
this on the fly is I didn't write in the
toilet scene there was a toilet and I
was like what if we what if we have him
having a revelation on the toilet
because we knew he'd need a revelation
and he would pop up and he would go or I
knew we would and it was like can we
have him on the toilet and then the rest
of the team was like sure and they'll
ugh
this is like $20,000 camera rig in the
bathroom like this is just like it was a
few years of jail cells and like just
one of them happened to be lit and we
were just like yeah why don't we oh we
just cram it in there and see what
happens so we did just like I love fun
like it's fun to work with people that
are flexible like that that don't have
like an adherence to absolute strictness
of what it was and it and what its quote
unquote supposed to be okay so now I'm
gonna bring up a deleted scene if I can
oh also funny only enough the I didn't
know the video is gonna be titled
Wilford mother-loving wharfs Ash until
the day before I uploaded the video the
working title that I had was actually
called Sunday evening heat as a parody
of Saturday Night Fever probably Sunday
evening heat was a porn videos name like
one of those parody porns that would
have done Saturday Night Fever but
that's just I didn't know what I was
doing so I stopped doing that but there
was another take of there was another
take gosh I'm not gonna be able to find
out which one which am I which one would
you have this not showing me any
thumbnails
let me try opening it in I'm gonna open
my premiere file this is going to be
this is gonna be a nightmare if the
whole stream crashes it's just because
everything exploded but
gonna it's gonna be there real soon but
via this this deleted scene and I'll
show you a few like scenes that like we
didn't really delete a lot of scenes we
didn't actually have that many bloopers
to be perfectly honest just because we
were on such a tight schedule we didn't
get a chance to goof around too much but
this one was one that I actually wrote
in and we ended up not using because
when I was editing I was like that
doesn't really fit like it's really
funny but gosh if it doesn't fit oh you
guys want to see like the actual
nightmare of the the actual nightmare of
the premiere file it's right here yeah
this is um that's that's what the that's
what you render down to get the video
and like I had to render this a few
times because I had to render out
lossless with the ending without the
ending because these transitions at the
end like were super harsh like this is
just layers of dialogue sound effect
like one of the great things about doing
audio with the professional audio mixer
is we have audio from a lot of sources
so I have audio from loft we art wearing
lofts he's got one boom he's got two
another boom like a wider boom he's got
a closed boom like layering those sounds
makes dialogue a lot more robust like in
a lot of audio engineering sometimes
they capture the same audio source from
a lot of different microphones just
because when you layer those on top of
each other like it just sounds more
robust the the sound is better it's more
true to life when you have a lot of
microphone ears on it and you play it
over so I was doing that it was just
like this nightmare of like constant
constant constant constant stuff but yes
so let me see if I can find the correct
one that I was doing to get everything
I got dig for this this will be just
better in the long run for me finding
these I think anyway the sequence one or
was it sequence - how was it sequence 3
3 was it 3 I think it might have been 3
yeah it was 3 ok so but this doesn't
have all right love trust another hood I
forgot when I was pulling the footage
hardest thing about editing one of these
is just the sheer amount of footage that
you have to work with this is over 2
hours of footage not even half of what
we shot in the first day like it's just
it's an astronomical amount of footage
and that's good you want as much footage
as we possibly could because we covered
this from a lot of angles and so having
that just in general was really really
beneficial let me see if I can find this
this isn't even gonna be worth it you
guys are gonna look at me and be like
then this good thing you cut it out
there you stupid idiot I'm gonna be like
ok well no need to be mean about it ok
here we go alright so yeah so this is
the deleted scene that we had
because I wanted this escalation of like
his different vices that he had going on
before he contact about to shoot up some
here it is we just have to so many of
these sweeps from right to left over and
over and over again it is like
and yeah didn't didn't end up using it
and then I told them that like yank hard
her you got a really yank it like come
on you're really stressed that's the
kind of direction that I have it really
janky so like I almost put that in the
final one but not didn't work at all so
you can't really see but there's strings
every [ __ ] where everywhere like
absolutely destroying this entire thing
with strings also I want you to like the
the sheer difference in terms of like
having the excuse me having the color
correction there and not is so amazing
like just I'll never not work with raw
footage again because just being able to
pull these colors out of it was and I'm
not a color corrector I want to be very
very frank about that I am NOT a color
corrector but just being able to do this
like with these colors like just added
so much more flexibility and depth and
like I could change like the mood of it
and hit him harder with this like and
when when when wharfs ass is doing his
thing like you know I could I could
really bust out the colors there and and
like make it seem like super super super
super over-the-top where we're even is
it I don't even know to my favorite
scene in the whole thing like just the
dance bit just like [ __ ] gorgeous
colors just like and and just look at it
without like ice this one yeah just look
at this without like without it still
looks good but just ball it's like this
like this explosion of colors it's so
beautiful ah
it's like hits you in the face just like
oh and that's that's kind of like I
wanted that feel of it and it's just
like oh my god this is me nerding out
about like [ __ ] but just oh my god
what is this supposed to be is that
paying your bum
oh [ __ ] yeah good god love it yeah and
this is obviously this is oversaturated
like this is way over I think there's
like 200 yeah this is that 200 because I
wanted this one to contrast so
harshly with the the film noir black and
white and even the film noir like
halftone this is it I believe this is at
25 percent saturation I'm pretty sure
yeah this is 25 so at a hundred percent
this would look so very differently
completely different mood and I wanted
them to blend together because of the
way you know his film noir was butting
up against it so this had to look way
under and this had to look way over like
that was just the natural of it and then
once you get to here I believe this is
at 150 yeah not not quite over the top
but still way saturated so like I used I
used color as like a storytelling Ellen
and in this anyway that's enough of that
let's get back to let's get back to
watching the video here you think you
are if you've been on the run for years
on the years eventually you're gonna
make a mistake word of advice if you're
running away from your problems never
become too attached to anything family
lovers briefcases on top of your car
some things are best left behind the
Colonel's a slippery one
shedding names as easily as a snake
sheds a few pounds before bikini season
he's gone through suiting him after
suiting him trying to cover his tracks
but he always manages to okay here's the
next thing that not not many people
talked about just some in this shot this
is one continuous shot by the way this
is this easily going up here if there's
no vahini season no babies gone through
suiting him after suiting them suddenly
weber tracks well that's weird
where'd that come from whoa yeah that's
that's a single shot suddenly know that
babe the pseudonym after suiting him
trying to cover his tracks a little bit
of that was a very slight of hand of
Mick and then just a little bit of video
editing to cover up a small flicker of a
hand that passed up but yeah okay anyway
also for this car scene I have to
commend the people who like Dan and all
those guys like we called it he called
it the poor man's process and my
goodness was it amazing what he pulled
off so how many of you guys out there
would even know that that car was not on
the road like cuz it wasn't that car was
not on the road in any way shape or form
yeah I mean some of you may have been
like I was on a green screen right he's
like not even a nope not even a green
screen
not even a green screen it was in this
warehouse this is where we shot every
single car scene this that's it that's
just like this is it we had people
running lights to pass lights by the car
over and over again to simulate the look
of cars passing by this thing and it's
just like it was just it was
astronomical like what you could get
away with just by like fudging it this
way yeah I mean it looked like totally
convincing and like not completely
obviously but he had it down too
details like if you look here one of the
one of the things that I like find the
most interesting also with like the the
the the briefcase Joker's but this that
looks like a that looks like a headlight
that was just that looks like a
headlight that honestly if you if I
didn't point it out that that's not a
headlight that looks just like a
headlight that looks like a car's
headlight for a motorcycle headlight but
that's just Dan and his lighting guys
knowing so minutely what little splash
of light against like just the edge of
the frame here will look like in
comparison to everything else so let me
play you a video real quick about this
just because I find it's so fascinating
I was taking this while I was waiting
for us to get through this this part
here so this video is everything in
action
and just some guy some guy pressing his
foot into the car and that's what it
looks like
and that's it that's it yeah if you're
doing something low-budget and we were
doing something low-budget but if you're
doing something low-budget
you don't need amazing to look good all
it has to do is tell the idea we just
needed the idea that he was driving and
like we did it in a convincing way that
really like solely the case the whole
thing off of your car the briefcase
jokes we just had a string pull a
briefcase off and someone threw papers
into a fan left behind like that's it
that the gag is done and like it's it's
done in a way and then you you you
splices some shots like this where we
just went out and we filmed some shots
we blew him out and it was just like
yeah this perfect transition footage to
make it look like he's driving and like
that's all you need that's all you need
to tell a story it was like you just did
and it's so brilliant cuz I never would
have thought of that but dan dan knows
his [ __ ] and he's just like oh we could
do this with this and it's like does
look so good and he had the slider and
like this sliding shot like we just
moved the backlight tarp that we had
behind it to move over we adjusted the
lights a little bit still have them
going and we just Adam look and it was
just like we had a light pop-up just as
he was going there and then we just got
a shot outside of someplace that looked
like it would match the theme which is
the moonlight roll away which some of
you might recognize from the ninja sex
party video cool Patrol it's a lovely
place and it's just like it's it's just
amazing what you can get away with and
then the disco was a completely
different location like this transition
was just completely completely different
so it's uh it's it's just fascinating
like the the ways that you can make
things happen when you just want them to
happen like that if you if you want to
make things work like you can just make
it work there's there's no two ways
about it okay so let's get into the
disco my favorite part of the whole got
videos discus
[Music]
the Colonel's always wonderful
eccentrics what is latest for some takes
the entire shop
[Music]
you
sorry hey how's it going I'm here sorry
okay so I'm gonna stop it right here
sorry that was making me laugh I just
wanted to give a shout out to the extras
that stopped by these guys answered the
call for the text that I sent out
through that number the digits number
like they texted I texted people in the
LA area they responded they went to an
email and they showed up and they just
dedicated their day to be here and just
dance and have fun and I'm so
unbelievably grateful that they did it
was so nice of them to like just show up
and be here and they made it perfect and
these guys showed up and it's just like
you guys are perfect because we wanted
like the crowd to close in and just like
stop the the detective in his tracks and
just being able to see like like this
this this orchestration of just beauty
here and the song like these two guys
hey can you just squish Mik real hard
and just like dance like there's no
tomorrow and they're like yeah sure all
right I think their names was Marco and
Lopez I believe I'm not a Harbison sure
I have a list of all the names somewhere
but I mean you'll see like in the
background like this guy's in the band
and he was up on stage but you know he's
down here she was one of the dancers but
she's down here cuz we just made it work
with like the limited number of extras
that we had but it looked like the whole
place was full right like it looked like
we had a hundred people in there we have
there and we just moving around as much
as we could so good I love this so much
yeah just like we got a lot of b-roll of
like just people dancing and like yeah
so good like I'm just so happy with how
this scene worked out cuz again it was
another thing that I had no idea I was
gonna work I've never worked with extras
before and like to just be able to go up
to him be like hey I know this seems
weird but we're just gonna have some fun
like I'm gonna try to keep the a/c on as
much as we can and we're just gonna get
we're just gonna get through this it's
gonna be a great time we're gonna take
breaks if you need water like will get
water it was just so nice to be able to
like hang out with these like these
people and just like have some fun with
it and just have a good time
so yeah
happy about that oh and just to go back
one small thing this this like whole
sequence was we had this various eye
I basically the the backup dancers lay
okay we're gonna do this thing where we
just Bop like this eight times then
we're gonna go like this eight times and
then we're gonna go like this for four
counts this for four counts and then
we're going to repeat so it's not all
that and then we did some freeform
[ __ ] there but that's a horrible
picture but I wanted to stop here
because I wanted to show you some
alternate costumes that we were thinking
of for wharf sash before we landed on
this we had a few other options from as
simple to a color palette shift like we
had this other alternative where the
pants were pink and the shirt was yellow
because that felt like originally in my
mind it felt like that might have been
more in tune if you zoom in real close
you can see my nipple right there and it
felt like this would have been more in
line with like his previous costumes but
when I looked at it it just didn't feel
right it seemed to normal it was it was
wasn't exactly like disco in a weird way
and so so when we came down to it it was
just like that doesn't really work like
what can we do to like change it out and
it was just like okay what about what
about what about this we had like yellow
pants we had this power suit like this
connected like whatever suit here and it
was yellow jacket and and I was like
this doesn't feel right like something's
not right about like this one's the
jackets huge and so it was like did we
change the jacket out and like this
looks stupid and we're like I could see
it but then I really can't see it and
and the whole unfair thing is that make
like put on his first set of clothes it
was like looked at [ __ ] amazing I was
like god damnit Mick you handsome
bastard why do you got to look good
immediately we had like one other coat
option and he changed that out and it
was like okay all right you're fine
whatever we got just fine enough so then
we landed finally on this this kind of
idea and originally there was gonna be
like a gold chain in this and was just
like I took the jacket off I put on the
chain and I was just like hey you know
there's something to this there's
something to this oh if you zoom in real
close you can see my nips and it was
just like there was
think to this but unfortunately the mic
for the love had to be placed right here
in the clattering of the metal against
it just made it so that it was too
difficult so we tossed that out and we
landed on you know this this outfit and
you know this was the first test of if
you zoom in real close here you can see
Oh Trevor Trevor Taylor starts with the
T he was the I believe he's the line
producer I believe this is this is him
popping out of the bathroom the
expression of shock is very honest here
because this is really funny to me but
this test was important because know if
you look real close you can't see my
name nops thankfully but this was
important because we originally didn't
know if this pink on the tips was gonna
work because we we were originally gonna
bleach the edges of it and dye it pink
but with since that synthetic mustaches
like this you can't bleach them there's
nothing to bleach it's a thin synthetic
synthetic fiber my Lisp it's a synthetic
fiber I can't do s's and fuzz like I
have trouble with the source and thing
words like that but the synthetic fiber
doesn't bleach out there's no color to
bleach it just is what it is so we ended
up painting it and out in the real world
doesn't look perfect but on camera with
color correction it sold it like it did
and like this was a mustache that we got
from the same place we got the Colonel's
mustache ami got this and then it was
just a slight upturn and I was like
that's good because at the end of the
day the very important thing to remember
about this is this my intention of this
bridges the gap between who killed
markiplier kernel and present-day wharfs
- this this version of war sesh exists
exactly in the middle the turning point
between where he was and who he is now
that the the moment of realization when
it comes to that
distance this is where he's
transitioning you know if there was any
it's it's a it's a loosely defined line
obviously of madness when he slipped
down the slope but if there was ever a
moment that I wanted to exist this was
the moment so that's like important in
both the characterization of of who he
is like the the environment that he's
experiencing this moment in time when
you tell a story you were always telling
a story in the mindset of why is this
moment important and this moment is
important to like both Abe and to wharfs
- like that's very integral to what I
was trying to get through in this but uh
more importantly some drugs okay anyway
so that's extremely important in my mind
to remember so those were just some
other alternate costumes of what could
have been but it ends up that we landed
on this and I'm very happy
[Music]
oh this was a scene I was like we had a
few shots of people running out and then
I was like what if people run out still
dancing like their dad this idea of late
wouldn't it be funny wouldn't it be
funny of people like we're running in a
panic but half of them were still
dancing that's why you see people go
like this later cuz you're like if your
birthday is from January to June you're
dancing if not you're not dancing and so
some people are like running in a panic
and some people feel like the party's
got also you'll see like oh wait wait
what is your bet so uh her right there
leaving the club turn right there on
stage that's not a story thing that's
just like we didn't have that many extra
so do with
[Music]
I love that moment so much that was
another thing where I was just like
wouldn't would it be funny if like we
had some guy in the background just like
completely oblivious to everything was
going on and just like freeze I just
loved this so much and there was a
better take of that there really was a
better take of that let me show you the
other take there was a better take but
unfortunately you'll see why I couldn't
use it it was so good though but I
couldn't use it
such a shame let me see if I can find it
somewhere here my computer lags whenever
I try to load up this goddamn project
okay I think it was this take this one
oh yeah it was this one yeah so we had a
we had a better take of it but it's just
like like I know music is so weird
just like the reaction of it is so good
but you could see like for safety
reasons because this is not a real gun
it's a BB but it's a very realistic real
fake gun
so for safety reasons just because we
had so many extras we had to pull the
clip just to like legally like there was
some something about it so you could see
that there was no and I I didn't want to
digitally add that in because it would
have been a pain in the ass to do so
yeah but man does one of my favorites
okay anyway so
get your ass down
don't move [ __ ]
[Music]
love it oh my god I love this sequence
so much just just something about it
just tickles me every time I watch it
just like there's like weak because I
didn't know how this is gonna turn out
but then when I was editing it like this
is the greatest thing ever
and when I was and when I went on when
I'm when I'm doing this sometimes like
happy little accidents like Bob Ross
says happy little accidents come across
this sinking right here like the down in
the scoop they're just tied into the
music before I even had to do anything
and I'm like oh my god I have to use
that shot now I was going to anyway but
I know I'm laughing at myself here but
it's is like it's so I love it when
things time up like that also wait what
was the what's the key to scoop for it
frame by frame a boom looks real donut
that's me I put in special effects there
you would never know boom it's even got
the gas after pretty good right boom
little tip on if you want muzzle flares
to look real they're always bigger than
you think they are and they got a cast
light that's the thing about it I did it
cheaply here because it lit up the
background too but it did the effect
like quick it's only one frame so like
it's got a cast light that's the thing
you have to cast light with it that's
something that people often forget
there's also if you're doing muddle
flares layer a few of them layer
multiple ones like I had some sparks
coming out of here
I had a big cloud I had a small cloud
these are separate clouds of fire this
is a separate element like and then
light it and then it looks realistic
when you play it's like okay smoke like
in the other frame here and it's like
[Music]
easy-peasy
easy free beautiful not too hard
look at me Pro Dodger who definitely
definitely missed me it didn't hit me at
all
and then woo-ping does me look at this
pro level special effects job that I did
definitely good and took a lot of time
to do
I bought the action essentials pack just
for this video anyway so um what I
wanted what I want to say here is just
to show you another little piece of
something that I like is just like just
this this that shot with the second spin
like just all of it together was easily
my favorite thing ever oh no it's a
nested I forgot this a nested sequence
alright we're diving just this whole
sequence I just really really love this
one just from start to finish of this
like it looks so stupid when you're when
you don't have the cuts yet it's the
music like when I when I had the when I
showed the story cut to the rest of the
team there was no music in it so when it
came down to this this looks brilliant
slow like cumbersome it looks it looks
ridiculous but if you see if you have
the idea in your head if you have the
idea in your head stick to your guns cuz
I knew this was gonna turn out I like
I've edited enough stuff and I'm like I
know this can turn out I know this can
work if you've got an idea and you're
like I know this can work because I've
done things before I like to stick to it
because this is like the peace of that
like just this I didn't know how this
was gonna be my favorite thing in the
world like rap and then this like I
didn't know that I was gonna have my
favorite thing I dog waylaid here but I
was able to cut into that one I don't
even think I used this one did I use
this why I'd must have used this with
this spin I think I used a different
spin for this like it was uh yeah this
spin way better spin but it's just like
I do it multiple times so that you can
cut in and piece it together like this
one better no not a better dodge but
better spin like just like like that's
not sped up this should
me spinnin real hard bling is it sped up
I might be sped up ah sped up on her in
20% that's been up but yeah it's just
like ah I love it I love editing I love
editing because it's like when you I
love writing I love I actually really do
like directing and I like editing just
because it's like it's it's you're
painting with colors that you made like
you film it you film it you have the
idea you make the colors and then you're
painting it together so it's like it's a
multi-step process that relies on you
sticking to what you know and also
adapting to what you don't know which is
just sometimes really really really fun
takes a lot of work but as a fun three
days okay so you can see here like the
the color groups in this in this shot
color goes down back to I believe it's
like 75 or 100 saturation you can't see
sorry okay you see the color Duprey
right here you can see the color groups
from top to bottom and then that's that
it just goes with the music it's down on
the ground do I know what ok so
everyone's favorite question why the
hell what the hell how the hell is Worf
stash back here from theories of is that
even is that even really like Worf past
that he's talking to is that really
something like like whoa did he move no
number one I want to point out no he
didn't move there's a shoulder here we
put a shoulder there for a reason
also this was just an idea I had on set
I was like wouldn't it be cool if we had
this this idea and like the main the
main thing I wanted to show about this
is it's less about trying to piece
together what war stash can do and more
just showing things aren't what they
seem that is this is the first not that
not the first but this is the most
obvious idea that things are not what
they seem like that's that's pretty much
it I mean if you didn't pick it up from
him shooting at Worf stashed in Worf
stash just dancing the bullets away this
is like the most blatant red signal both
to the audience and to a but that
something is weird it can't see it of
course he doesn't know but it happens
when he questions that that I wanted to
convey it happens when he questions
something he he's like he's like get
down on the how do you not know who I am
in what universe where I have been
chasing you all this time how do you not
no like it happens exactly at the same
time like I Ana and I really wanted to
have that and it's just like this is a
casual thing also the only time war sesh
has ever been able to take a drink out
of that he's never been able to take a
drink any other time right here right
now how are you yeah so basically from
from here on out it's just like the rest
of this is just dialog that I thought
was funny conveyed that wharfs - doesn't
know Abe Abe is still just like very
very serious about all of this and yeah
that's pretty much Dave who's Dave Dave
is just a random name that works s
pulled out deed Dave who's Dave like
he's just he's just trying to connect
the dots of who this is this is not like
owes memories failing he's pulling up a
date this is just if you if you if
there's a guy that says he knows you and
you don't know him you're pulling a name
out of your ass and shooting for the
stars like that's why that's why he's
just like Craig Steve bill like it's not
any of those names he's just trying he's
just taking stabs in the dark and then
just committing to one just because he's
like oh sure way too many people to even
count and this is just like the martini
comes up and I just this like everyone
loves the martini I love the martini I
hated the martini during filming but I
love like the idea of the martini like
throughout it because I wanted some kind
of some kind of device for worse - to
hold that shows just like why does he
have a martini I just want people to ask
like a lot of these things that I wanted
in this video is like okay like that's
fine it's a little bit of not reality
that like it's something that you can
accept that leads you down into the road
of like this is weird it's weird for the
second weird
no one really I saw no one in the theory
world like questioned why he had a
martini or how he had a martini they
were only worried about did he get a
drink out of the martini like that I
love that concept of something like wear
something so nonchalant and it doesn't
have any place into it but people care
so much about the martini look look what
our boy have a sip of his martini anis
is like I love I love that idea there's
no big story element around the martini
that's not like the key to all of this
it's just like that's just a simple
thing that I added and and is it gives
it gives a character more
personification like in an improv they
teach you to when you are in a scene
object work you want to do something you
want to hold something you want to be
working on something because it gives
you more definition of your character
through how you interact with an object
like worse - trying desperately to get a
drink out of this get a sip out of this
damn drink and what's happening here is
like what I was going for is like it's
butting up against my mustache and I
can't get to the straw okay so
transition obviously a transition that
horse ash doesn't fully understand how
he got from A to B but that's okay oh
it's alright he's seen it before it's
happened before why not
you ran a real good race there buddy and
then the film noir kind of like jazz
some light smooth jazz kicks in it shows
that like this is in the detective story
now it went from the club very bright
even like even like their dialogue after
like the the music went out still bright
still colorful still like not a hundred
percent in either of their elements but
still colorful kind of like 5050 this is
like a meeting ground between the two of
them like they're there they're both
equal parts of this like moment like
this is and I like to show the band just
like nonchalantly like when the hell is
this [ __ ] gonna be over so we can get
back to the party I just love that about
them yeah so anyway in here
yeah you ran a real good race there
buddy it's the end of the road for you
the law is gonna throw every book they
have at you and after that they're gonna
throw you in a Cell and after that
they're gonna throw away the key and
after that they're gonna throw that cell
into a lake
but not before I throw a few things at
him first we're gonna play pin the tail
on the donkey
but he's the donkey and the tail is my
feelings but I shouldn't get ahead of
myself I only get one night with him to
fill the hole in my heart he left behind
it's finally time to get some answers at
some point
no we didn't date the hole is a metaphor
for when you shot me in the okay more
more movie magic is just like this this
shot all it is is a guy with a light
running at the car that's all it is
that's all it is and I cut it in a way
that makes sense logically like if I
bring up the and bring up the premiere
file again like Oh like you can do so
much with just some lights controlled
environment and a few cuts like this
this is all it was like there's no
special effects here like we didn't need
any it conveys the message conveys me a
few sound effects that's it there's
nothing there there's obviously no one
there and also when you're cutting a
little tip for people when you're
cutting to a different frame you want to
repeat the action just a little bit of
the previous frame like in this one he's
already turned all the way forward but I
want to catch him turning again and as
the video moves it's like you don't
notice it in the moment because your
brain connects the dots automatically
that's a lot of the reasons why movies
in 24 like get away with a lot of the
tricks they do and if you're editing 24
frames per second footage versus 30
frames per second footage or even 60
frames per second footage you can get
away with a lot more and you you you can
let the brain fill in the gaps between
information like this the lights already
asked him but the lights just getting on
me and the light passes me but then when
I cut back here it's a different shot of
the light passing again but then he's
moving so it's it's technically in your
brain a different moment that continues
the light when you're watching this like
some of you obviously can pick this out
because you're have a good eye for it
but the average person watching this
it's convincing like the lights passing
it's very frantic with the cuts because
more cuts man your brain accelerates to
the action that's happening and then
it's like diving repeat the dive and
then come back and then jostle like we
went why you can see my fro going just
to look right there laughs right just
enough clues to give the eye something
to follow it's like this seems totally
cool like this seems totally fine and
like if you look at any one of them
individually it doesn't look right like
oh whoa that's too quick like I wanted
it to last longer and you can make
something last longer by having multiple
multiple where am I having multiple
little little frames of it you can oh
and then that's it but that was too
quick what we want is the drama of the
whole thing and lasts exactly as long as
it needs to be and it's not perfect I'm
not saying this is perfect this is not
this is not like graduate film school
level editing here this is just simple
tricks that I did I didn't look up a
tutorial to do this I just felt it out
it was like that's definitely passable
I'm definitely okay with it why not why
wouldn't I be
and that's it by the way so sorry I just
wanted to nerd out about that for a
little bit honey switch back holy [ __ ]
that was close
what the hell does that have to do with
how did you how are you how many fingers
am i holding up for aardvark
pumpernickel what are you doing
Calabasas are you okay how are you in my
head why are you so sir get out of my
head
[Music]
[Applause]
I love that I love so much of this video
you don't understand how much I love
this video I am so happy with how this
came out like I'm so happy with how it
came out because not not only does it
show like hey this stuff can happen in
this stuff can happen on a budget and
it's possible to keep doing it but also
just like for my own personal sake like
I have learned enough to this point that
I can make will something like this
whenever I want like that's such a
freeing thought for me and it's taken
six and a half years of learning about
like how things work and when I when I
personally come from a background where
I went into YouTube being like I wanna
make sketch comedy but I can't I don't
know how and now I can make this almost
movie quality level thing and it's like
it's there's obviously some nuances to
it that aren't professional and like
there's stuff about it that's not
perfect but it's like this is really I
like honestly I can look at this and I'm
very proud of how this came out why not
say that I'm not proud of who killed
mark Blaire and I'm not proud of like a
date with Mark Blair those are great
things but also those had flaws and
those were learning experiences this
comes down to something where it's even
more and there's parts of this video
that I don't know how to do I don't know
how to light those scenes correctly I
don't know how to make like sure the
cameras in focus all the time like doing
that stuff being able to like play to my
strengths which is stitching a story
together and editing it together and
writing it in the first place and and
then adding in these strengths of people
that really know their [ __ ] like that's
a really cool experience and I wouldn't
I wouldn't be here unless like you guys
gave me the chance to do this so it's
just really cool but anyway I'm getting
it's taking way too long just like
getting into this so I want to cover a
few things real quick a lot of people
were like oh my god how is he in the
detectives head and a lot of people were
like trying to quantify like the the how
the why the the what of it and I I'm not
gonna explain too much about it because
in explaining too much about it you get
even more questions because at the end
of the day it's like what Wharf stash
was said and it's like what I wrote very
intentionally at the end of it you're
too focused on the minutiae of it the
deep
tails the who killed who the who slept
with who like it's it's not only just a
message to Abe it's a message to anybody
watching it because it's and it's not
just tongue and cheek being like don't
look into it too much it's it's
important to remember that the viewer in
this universe isn't just a person it's
character the viewer is a character
that's something that cannot be forgiven
forgotten in anything that I do for
these like that may change the future
but in this universe the viewers a
character do not forget that ever so
anyway that's I just want to like be
very clear about that like don't focus
too much on the minutia of it like a lot
of works has character is about this
doesn't make sense but oh well like it's
fine Abe doesn't have that same mindset
you know like that's why he's so
conflicted about it like he's so
unbelievably conflicted about it because
it doesn't gel with his version of
reality like his version of reality is
like his in is in his own mind and he he
he like justifies it like I draw a lot
of inspiration from other sources when I
make these things because I feel like
there's a lot of ideas out there that
are really cool like in and I'm not and
again nothing I'm saying is like
answering question I'm not answering any
questions here that's not what I'm doing
right here and not until I get to the
end of it like of this watcher but I
just want to say right here right now
number one don't focus on the minutiae
of it don't number two don't try to
forget that the viewer is a character
and number three
like I draw a lot of inspiration from
other ideas that doesn't mean that
they're exact copies of the idea but in
for example soma when you were playing
in soma you thought the main character
thought he was human the whole time he
justified it in his mind
reality shaped itself to be that thought
but on closer observation it turns out
he was a machine when he looked in that
mirror first time he looked in that
mirror it was fine he was a human second
time he looked in that mirror he was a
machine what's the truth and what's the
lie like that concept is very
interesting to me and I'm again this
isn't answering a question in this video
this isn't answering a question in any
thing in the universe this is an idea
that I like and something that I can
utilize in terms of storytelling that I
can appreciate
mean that it answers anything not
answering any questions here just
remember that and just like keeping a
mind open to that possibility
yeah because one of the things that I
wanted to do in this video is to not
convolute the story anymore than it did
there were so many changes that I wanted
to make in hukou markiplier during it
that I ended up like crossing the
streams on a lot of things and I didn't
get my point across in the way that I
wanted to and therefore I tried to make
my point after the fact and you can't do
that like I realized very quickly I
can't do that that doesn't mean that I I
don't beholdin anything I said when I
was explaining it that just means that I
wish I was able to plan it better and
tell what I wanted to tell in the story
itself instead of explaining it
afterwards that's why I'm saying here
I'm not answering any questions in the
video because this video does a great
job at explaining the concepts and I
know that because there are some people
in the theory world on tumblr and
whatnot that have almost exactly nail on
the head said what I wanted to say in
this and that tells me that I did
decently enough that people can get the
idea behind it so continuing before I do
that I want to show you like the various
takes that we have trying to get that
right the the Zippy's app
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this is like just a screaming endlessly
just over and over and over again our
throats were like so thrashed by the end
of this we just super funny like I have
an idea about that like me it's super
hard to direct and also be in the scene
at the same time is like so dumb oh yeah
this is just us doing it over and over
again
well just like practicing the zoom for
the transition who's gonna let this play
so funny because like when you watch the
video you don't realize that there's
just these moments look look how long it
takes me to get my face into Worf stash
territory just look how long it was one
two three four five and then we're
locked in like that's how long it takes
me five full seconds to get my face to
go wharfs this was the one I used was so
funny
[Music]
Oh whenever I would come back from like
a film shoot oh just be like Amy you
have to see this cuz every day that I
came home from this I was like this is
so good it looked so Friday like when
there I showed her the disco stuff she
was like I'm gonna cry this is so pretty
I was like oh god it's so good so yeah
that's that's that that's what I wanted
to show you oh that's so much all right
continuing on we're gonna speed up a bit
enough case your ass is mine for the
next 24 hours and I'm gonna take my
sweet time with that ass to get answers
out of it from you
you
did I do it again
I did it again god damn it damn it damn
it damn it damn it damn it damn it damn
it damn it damn it I'm sorry okay let me
back up a bit let me just loo okay here
we go
here we go we're going back we're going
back cuz I'm an idiot
alright so what I was saying was I loved
writing Mick's character he played the
detective so unbelievably well because
some of you some of you may know this so
some of you may know that the detective
originally in who killed markiplier was
supposed to be played by me he was going
to be another version of myself that's
played like all over the place and that
would have made it physically impossible
so we brought Mick in because I knew
Mick I knew he's a voice actor I was
like hey you i I visualized you could be
a good detective like character would
you like to be a part of this and of
course he said yes and then he just made
the detective he made the detective he
made the detective like oh he brought
him to life and so when I made this
series like or this video here and I
wanted to tell the story of like worse
ash from then to now like there was no
other character than it could be with
him besides Mick and like another thing
that I've learned about storytelling is
is you don't get character development
or you don't understand a character just
by him being by himself you understand a
character based on how he interacts with
other people and there's no other
character that had more deep ingrained
need to interact with wharfs - then the
detective like he was such a perfect
thing because I also set up this whole
idea with the detectives line from the
end of who killed mark Blair the last
the fourth part of it where he went
colonel you can hear this
you better run yeah like it was so
perfect so if you guys haven't given
love to Mick yet like give them
some love show him all the love in the
world go subscribe to his stuff he makes
cool animations like he's a great voice
actor just makes the best love Mick is
so good yeah so when it comes down to
what we have here like it's just like
this scene I didn't know how I was going
out because I I didn't know how I was
going to like show it and I didn't know
how I was gonna showcase it but just
Mick just launched into this avalanche
of like emotion and like perfect like
nuances that the dialogue multiple takes
like it just made it beautiful so great
enough with your [ __ ] do you have
any remorse any remorse at all for the
things you've done or are you too much
of a coward to face your crimes well
there's no need for name-calling words
can hurt you know you should be kind and
what name is it William Jay Wilson
Jackson Bartholomew the third well now I
actually married it Wingull heimer
wait just wiggle himer
after name after name after name just so
you could distance yourself from the
real name you should be called
Hey okay so getting through all that
like it's just such it was so nice to be
able to write this the scene cuz a lot
of like what the film noir stuff in this
is its cliches right it's it's cliches
this is the moment this is like a mixed
characters moment he he's he he knew
this day was come he was going to
confront the colonel and he was gonna
show him all of his crimes and he was
going to like have his time to like
point his finger and like he doesn't
know what he's gonna get out of it but
he's practiced this speech he's
practiced all this he knows what's going
on but one important thing is one of
these names surprises him if he's been
looking at these things forever and ever
and ever
why would one of these names surprise
him why would why would one of them
surprise him like he's reading it for
the first time like he's like this
speech he's been waiting like and this
is just a callback to them when this was
stuck in the beginning but he's just
he's been waiting for it you could see
it in him he's easily he's gonna take a
sweet time with that ass this is his
time like as all this look at all this
evidence look at all just look at the
evidence go look at the evidence this is
like and then like but one name doesn't
ring true like that's just a little clue
that I wanted in there it's not just cuz
it's a silly name it's like it's also
just like it's show-stopping
it's show-stopping in a way cuz he's
like on his tirade and then just stops
like he's what why would you not know
that anyway
so I just wanted to point that out
aybe hey it's been years how are you how
are you doing how's my family I'm doing
just peachy buddy because I've been
waiting a long long time for this day to
come
so we could sit down have a chat catch
up good and proper that took so many
scenes together it takes to get right it
took about six seven takes of just like
slow pan cuz I had to like we had to
hold the rope so it looked realistic I
had to drop the rope as close to my
chest as possible and it came down I had
to lean down left out of my chair I
crawled under the camera because this is
huge rail setup so I couldn't go behind
it cuz we were back as far as we could
go so I had to crawl under under it on
my belly below the ground I bet there's
another video showing that I may be is
there a video showing that oh I don't
know if there is I don't think there is
okay I don't think there is because we
wouldn't have shot anything where I
would have had to do that but it's just
like me crawling on the ground like that
and it's it's just like it was very
important for this moment because this
is like this is the first moment when
Abe is confronted by the fact that Worf
stache is weird like it's just like it
says he's looking he's looking straight
at him he's like if you imagine if you
were just looking at someone tied up in
a chair you're looking at him you're
you're in the middle of his moment he's
been waiting a long long time for this
like and then he's just [ __ ] not
there like it's just like what the [ __ ]
yeah it's just like look so young
showings far in the future for Worf
stash Mick just improvise so many good
lines about that like he ripped like
that that thing so many different times
and just like this I love just the
cutaway to this show it's so funny
also how did you get your ass out of
that chair you're gonna tell me and
what's beautiful is like Mick did such a
good job in like his his like
maintaining of his cadence like because
those are different shots we move the
camera so those are completely different
times that we shot that but blend so
seamlessly it's like he's so good she
probably carved mine out I've been
collecting them every single scrap of
evidence this whole time so that one day
another things is just a small another
clue like just I've always had them I've
always had them mmm that's of course
I've had them and then the reason every
single like he's always had them and
then he has like brain catches up
remember like what I said about soma and
this isn't specifically it but this is
an example of where my idea of it comes
in like reality is not gelling but his
brain is making up why it makes sense
like it's like of course I've had them
I had them before I have them now I have
them for you I'm hey I have them of cry
at him I collected them like for you yes
that's intentional just for everybody
wondering I just I wanted something that
wasn't over-the-top like just just in
case like just again I'm just
reinforcing the same idea there's
nothing new in a lot of these things but
it's reinforcing it just so people can
get the pattern like this is this tiny
little like shake here this tiny thing
that's it and there's a little noise
there's a little shake and that's it
that's it like but I want a small thing
like the martini small thing like just
small thing it doesn't have to be big
grandiose like getting out of a chair
and moving across but just reinforcing
the idea I want to I want to get it more
and more
about all the horrible things you've
done once they throw you in a cage then
throw away the key and then throw that
how the hell do you keep doing that
please get jumbled so easily so when the
where the why the how of it all who can
keep track of it seriously need to get
back in the chair I've got more rope
maybe that'll work worth a shot oh oh
he's a lot of people question yes that's
Damien's picture yes it's just like I
say I wonder what exalter you've seen
him maybe I should stop by that's all I
say and like people can read into that
whatever they want but all it is is just
like it's what I felt he would say like
if you saw that picture at that moment
so like a lot of people could like draw
a lot of conclusions out of it but it is
again don't look into it and that's not
to say don't look into it because I
didn't think about it because I did
think about it and I meant that very
specifically for a reason but also that
reason doesn't have to be anything too
complicated that's what I'm saying about
that okay this is this is like the most
heavy-handed clue that I could possibly
give and probably the clue that a lot of
people started to understand what was
going on the people that did get it like
this clue right here it may seem like an
off-the-cuff joke but this is a very
clear reference to midnight on the earth
waiting on the or midnight on the
audience first wait no yeah murder
midnight murder murder on the Orient
Express that is very clearly a reference
to Murder on the Orient Express a lot of
people like like this glosses by like
it's just a joke people get it people
don't get it if they don't get it they
don't care like it's just something
telling about the future like of
something else but a lot of people
latched on the fact like oh that
probably hasn't happened yet and not
what it was some people did some people
didn't like Murder on the Orient Express
is a book about and a movie but a book
about murder on a train stuck in the
snow the clue being spoiler alert that
all the passengers committed the murder
together like that's the idea but it's
not about what the story is it's about
the fact that he's talking about clearly
a story that everyone knows it's just
like that is the crux to take out of it
that's the idea to take out of it not
the fact that it hasn't happened yet
although that is something to keep in
mind not the fact that I'm being cheeky
about it with Worf stache and like act
and like breaking Abe's mind with this
bomb of knowledge that I knows something
or he has something on the board that he
doesn't know anything about which which
is conveyed but the more important thing
to know is that it's a story and
obviously the bull doesn't do anything
and a lot of people like to draw and a
lot of people were like making tables
and stuff about like what's his power
like what's worse as power he's
invincible time traveler like
teleportation it's like that's not the
right mindset to go about it because
it's saying that war sash has powers is
suggesting that he has any control over
what he's doing or any idea what he's
doing in the first place like it's it's
it's the wrong mindset to go about like
yes it's happening but again focusing on
too much of the the details of it like
if he's not focusing on the details of
it why why should you like that's the
idea of I don't understand anything
this music is the Colonel's seem the
Colonel's theme from who kill markiplier
for those of you who remember there's
one thing I've learned after all these
years it's that nothing heals like a
good apology that like again I love that
I love the hug I had that in my mind it
turned out so perfectly I love that just
like everything moving on love it love
it love love love it love it love it
love it
um and what I love about this next part
is just I love mix performance so
[ __ ] much from here to the end of the
whole video Mick just steals the goddamn
show Mick is just like ah like just as
far as like a good truly good actor like
Mick is just super impressive here
unbelievably impressed I just want to
say I want to let this like ride to the
end I'll probably stop it once or twice
but yeah I want to let it ride as much
as I can is beautiful to you what kind
of sick twisted son of a [ __ ] beautiful
now what did we say about name calls you
killed people so many people you killed
my friends you killed my partner
you shot me now it seems to me like
you're trying to paint me as the bad guy
whoa
you
like you're trying to paint me as the
bad guy you are the bad guy
you
trying to paint me as the bad guy who
damnit I did it again damn it damn it
damn okay I didn't say much though I
just want to say this is the first time
I put the martini down this is the first
time I put the martini down right this
is this is the first time this is the
first time I put the martini down that
is the moment that's what I want to say
there I can't believe I keep forgetting
that I have no idea I think I hit it and
then I don't all right whatever so well
and also I want to say that this moment
here I just I could watch this over and
over again with this like I could like I
was I was in editing and over and over
again I was just like oh my god just
just like I could feel the rage just
like I could feel it burning just like
it was every time I want to do was so so
so like just powerful and it was
everything that I wanted out of the
detective like just the at first like
and a lot of the theme about this is
like the detectives in control but like
this is his moment this is a moment and
then this [ __ ] this murderous [ __ ]
comes in and is ruining his moment like
this is his moment like these are the
reasons this is his moment like he's
like it should not be his moment and
like all of his anger is starting to
come to a head his frustration at
reality like his his mind keeps bashing
up against the shore of reality being
like no this is this is what it is like
he goes and and in like - again to mix
credit like he goes from like
questioning doesn't understand anything
anymore he's like he's lost he almost
goes down the path that he's down at the
end and he does this a few times just
like the what the hell what the hell
what the hell like questioning
questioning questioning like like and
and one thing like Nick is like if we
compare all the way back to like this
moment everyone's favorite moment just
like the the quick flash of like what
the [ __ ] just like this this moment and
like you can compare like this to like
his his complete like loss of
understanding of the situation it's just
like it just keeps weighing on I mean
it's like this what again it's what I
was talking about she's like repeating
an idea over and over and over again -
like
idea idea idea it's the idea of not
understanding it's like the ideas like
sprouting roots in his mind is like this
idea and then his own version of reality
comes crashing forward for years and
years and years you've been chasing me
all around the world from a bedrooms two
bathrooms two ballrooms you've been
chasing me and you've been doing a real
bang-up job of it but and and forgive me
if this sounds insulting in any way what
would you say are our closest encounter
was before this very moment right here
when was her closest encounter yeah
before this very moment yes
that's easy it was when we when we
you know it was when you um that's when
you were I was hunting you down I was
stalking but you fled the country to uh
alright alright yeah you were off the
radar for three years but I got a hot
tip you checked up in in uh you shacked
up with okay before we go on to the next
section um I just want to say like just
again it's reinforcing the same thing
like this is where it's blatantly stead
stated like the where the idea comes to
fruition like this
this clue and also it's a clue for war
sash to worst ass doesn't know that that
a doesn't know like he doesn't know that
he doesn't know he from his mind mindset
everyone like this world doesn't make
sense so all the people in it like they
do they get that it doesn't make sense
to him like that's that's reality but
for just the moment here like when it
comes down to you seems like you're
trying to pay me as a bad guy
seeing the rage putting the drink down
taking it seriously like he's starting
to piece it together from what he sees
Donna's lap around the room and he's
like looked into it and like so Abe is
also he's asking this question not to
try to like break him but to try to get
an understanding for himself where he's
at this is a test this is a test of just
being like are you sure you understand
everything that you think you understand
like he's testing him to see like what
he really knows about it because Abe's
in the same boat Ames in the exact same
boat the only difference is a doesn't
know that the boats leaking you know
what I mean when was her closest
encounter before this very moment yes
that's easy it was when we
when we okay it's definitely not muted
okay yeah just imagine imagine like if
you were here in this moment you'd been
leading up to this you have all this
evidence you have all this things you
you you know you have evidence you know
you have evidence you know you have a
reason you know that you've been chasing
him for ever and ever ever but if you
were ever pressed on the details the
subject of it falls apart
it's as if he was told what he needed to
know but not what it was that he knew
you know he knew the concept of what he
needed to do but not the details of it
you know and like trying to pick that
apart like makes the threads of the
story fall apart and it's not like again
I'm not answering anything specifically
I'm just illustrating like what he's
going through
all right all right yeah hey you were
you were off the radar for three years
but I got a hot tip you shacked up in in
a math you shacked up with three years
what year was that exactly
what year it was
okay so this is like this is when it
breaks down he he's he's saying cliches
he sang cliches things that a detective
a film noir detective would be expected
to say he's saying things that he like
he that logically would make sense but
then when he tries to expound upon it he
can't fill the gaps like he just can't
do it like cuz like there's no substance
there in him like there's no character
development in him that explains all
these other nuances that he knows he did
you know what I mean
so like when he says like you fled the
country like fled the country that's
that's something that people do that's
that's something like you shacked up
with hot tip shacked up in with with
like that details fall apart and again
not answering I think it's just
reinforcing like he doesn't know and
like this is where the final
understanding the piece of the puzzle
that doesn't make sense for wharfs -
comes in like he wants to know when Abe
is
you
ah alright so for those of you who are
sleuths you will know that the last
piece of music when he's breaking down
is the same song from when Celine takes
you upstairs to the the Sears room to go
into the the upside down or whatever
don't read too much into like what that
means I just thought it fit with it but
this next piece of music is obviously
the music from the end of who killed
markiplier it's it's this lovely piece
that I absolutely have fallen in love
with in it it's just it's so subtle and
it's so it's so good I think in this
moment because it's just explaining like
the the what's going on inside his head
it's sorrowful it's slow it's it's it's
an understanding though and it's like
it's this cool piece of music and like
in this moment like he wore sash is
understanding and like I really just dad
again I'm I don't want to to my own horn
but I just love the way this came
together with with like Mick and number
one it's it was [ __ ] hot in this area
it was just so goddamn hot so that sweat
is real just from the heat of it like
just and he was like shouting and doing
this over and over again but just like
so so sweaty but just like this this
look of understanding this look of
honest true curiosity this complete
blankness this understanding like this
back and forth like I love because you
can write a bunch of [ __ ] you can write
a bunch of [ __ ] but when it comes down
to when it comes down to like expressing
feeling and emotion like words sometimes
can't do it like the the build-up and
the crescendo of like the emotion of the
last scene like the build-up and the
down of it and then like coming crushing
down not hard crush but it's just like
it just loses all steam every bit of his
everything it's just gone with one final
question it's just like a killing blow
to his understanding he's grasping at
straws like what you're obviously I know
what year duh but then it's just like
well it was and this is the last attempt
that his brain does to try
to rationalize anything and when he cut
when he comes up empty again it's just
like horses can see it
this is my favorite moment in the entire
video these three words three words just
like the way Mick says it just it was
everything I wanted to come across this
is why I love this video so much it's
just like it's so exactly what I want
and that's why I'm so proud of this one
and that's why I'm so proud like that
people are understanding is because it's
exactly how I wanted it to come out like
this is the first time that I've made
something that I don't want to change
anything about I don't want to change a
damn thing about this because I love it
so much
I've obsessed over this case for years
every
spend trying to hunt you down
so why can't I remember
am I crazy
I love this this moment like again Mick
I sing praises to make but for good
reason because not only is this like
just a [ __ ] beautiful power shift
remember this scenes started with Worf
stash in that chair like this this is
how this scene started and then suddenly
we see the detective in the chair like
it's it's literal power shift and that
was actually a mix idea during the thing
I didn't write that in that was Nick
just being like that's that's what I
wanted it's just like man it's just he
nailed this so hard obsessed over this
case
spend trying to hunt you down
it's why can't I remember
am I crazy
I that look I love that look that look
is just so it speaks volumes of like his
mental state and Mick just nails it
because it's it's this pleading it's
this honest question he like he's he's
asking the question to himself and he's
looking to the only person that can give
him confirmation for it someone that he
has every right to hate he is
practically begging begging wharfs - for
an answer - like what the hell is going
on he's like just this look that it's
two frames it's two frames and it's just
like it's just this pleading look like
you he's almost on the verge of tears
for like this question in his head am I
crazy
is he crazy and it's just like that's
exactly where I wanted the detective to
be at this point and Mick just nailed it
so good it's just like this this look
it's like this beautiful beautiful sad
look of this guy who's at the end of his
rope doesn't understand anything about
what's happening and it's like and of
course no the answer is no the answer is
honestly no not crazy
no not crazy in a world you you're not
crazy because the world doesn't make
sense you're not crazy because of that
the world is crazy and here like a lot
of people notice that I was blending in
between like the colonel and war stache
and I kind of just was doing that half
because I couldn't stick to one or the
other but half because I did want to
weave in between but here it's like
straight up colonel
like this is how the colonel talked
exactly just like it's impossible to
survive okay so with this like with this
I wanted to really really really convey
that like this is this is like what
we've all thought like everyone who's
watched this has thought because when we
go back to kill markiplier in the last
episode a bees shot a shot through the
heart this isn't like some people were
like he saved the bullet from when he
did it and he shot him right there no no
work sighs doesn't need to shoot him
again he's already shot him like this is
something the colonel shot him war
stache isn't shooting him like and don't
read too much into that like I'm not
saying they're two different people they
are they're the same person that changes
like down the tunnel of madness but it's
just like the colonel already shot the
detective and he apologized for it like
he's not gonna shoot him again yeah so
but this what what this is that's not a
heartbeat this is wrong that's not a
heartbeat
that's a gunshot so let me show you
exactly what that is like it's it's hard
to pick up but it was there was no way
that I could do it without it being very
subtle and not obvious because I didn't
want a loud booming noise here so what
this is is this is one second okay here
we go so this might be loud but bear
with me okay so this is from the
it's it's a 44 Magnum it is the exact
same sound effect I used when the
detective was shot in the first place
when they turn down the volume it's the
exact same when he shot him in who
killed markiplier that is the same sound
effect but distant echoing echoing
through like to this moment where it's
it's the last nail in the coffin that
this place doesn't make sense not that
it like the again the lesson isn't that
oh you're dead like that's not the
lesson the lesson is this doesn't make
sense that's the theme that's been
hammered like when it when i when i read
a story i try to like always I'm not
trying to now anyway I'm not trying to
introduce a new concept every single
time something happens I'm reinforcing
the same concept this doesn't make sense
that's what I'm doing it like it's
impossible to know things before they
happen yes yes it is impossible like
it's absolutely impossible
yeah and it's impossible for this
happened bowing and it's like I'm not
shooting works that isn't shooting him
again simply pointing out he was shot
like that is a gunshot and then this
practical effect of this uh thing also
move a pen this was just he he didn't
even realize that he was holding it was
at the end of the day and he he had to
wait there awhile to get this set up cuz
we we threaded a hose up and glued it to
the tip here and then we had blood
actually pumping out of that but so he's
holding the vape in there but it kind of
works out cuz the vape is there
throughout the whole thing
remember we shot this on the first day
and then everything else was I was like
put a vape in your and put a baby in
your mouth I was it like you know
whatever
that I couldn't wake up from my heart
was pounding Morse code to my ears but I
never learned the language my mind was
like a hamster ball rolling down the
freeway no matter how fast I went I
couldn't keep up with the flow it was my
first year of Clown College all over
again okay so like obviously he's going
into his own world he's retreating he
doesn't even realize he's doing it he's
he doesn't again doesn't even realize
he's doing it but in this like with the
the color it's not just he's slipping
into a monologue
he's slipping into his role again as the
detective like this language isn't
necessarily just to contemplate the the
reality of its himself justifying what's
happening in a way that makes sense to
his character like the detective a
detective would like a detective would
say these things a detective would say
these things in the face of crisis but
that's not that's not accepting it
that's not realizing it's it's seeing
like something that's so
earth-shatteringly like mind breaking
and handling it in the only way that
he's established persona knows how the
freeway no matter how fast I went I
couldn't keep up with the flow it was my
first year of Clown College all over
again
like it was my first year of Clown
College over again that's it's none of
the clown joke but and I he was gonna
keep going like he was gonna keep going
like he was probably if he if this hand
didn't come in here you know how these
beginning shots they they're slides
they're wipes they continue from one
scene to the next they keep moving they
keep moving he would have he would have
he would have drifted right off when I
say when I say when I say no drifting
off just yet I'm not saying no going to
sleepy sleepy bye-bye he's not passing
out from blood loss I literally mean
don't go anywhere I'm not done yet like
listen I'm not done yet
like no drifting off because if that
would have carried on then that would
have just been another like chapter in
the story of the detective and his crazy
adventure with like the colonel but
that's not what I see needs to happen
right here Worf stache sees that Abe
needs something Abe needs it like he's
he's unintentionally pushed Abe to this
point but he's not gonna leave him
behind at least not this time he's not
gonna leave him behind because he sees
like the the the the need of someone
who's in the exact same place as he was
and repeat was but I think the stress
you're a freshly born farm trying to
find your legs in
let's forget about all that we were
chasing and the killing and the shooty
shooty bang bang okay so everything that
I just said is exactly what I say in
here like I'm again not saying anything
new this is reiterating a point like
it's it's it was a shock for me too
like when cuz he sees Abe as he was long
time ago remember this is this is a long
time along the storyline for the kernel
into wharfs s not even at the end of it
not even close to the end of it not even
anywhere near where it was but it's a
long time he looked at the corkboard he
said we look so young it's been years
years for worse - but Abe Abe cannot
remember what year even happened he has
no recollection of anything happening
this takes place for Abe immediately
after the events of who killed
markiplier not ears like that's what I
wanted to stress in this one he thinks
it's been years his mind tells us so
many years like everything in his course
says it's been years he's been
collecting this evidence forever but he
can't remember a single scrap of it he
can't remember a single thing this is
immediate this is immediately after and
that's like something that Worf says
season Abe like he's a freshly born fawn
yeah and he's literally saying like why
should death be any differently don't
let don't let death get in the way of
you understanding this weird world or to
a more specific point not understanding
this weird world
yeah it's too much like he's presenting
too much right now so and poor sesh
knows this more such knows that too much
at a single point in time can be too
much for anybody even him and he's
already broken like so he
knows that the the detective like what
he needs is a break of character he
needs to get out of this this uh this
this depressing like film noir
black-and-white cycle that he's in right
now he needs some wine like that's it
literally this is word-for-word what the
war says things I didn't write anything
to be like subterfuge here I didn't
write anything to be like allegory or or
or anything like that alludes to
anything else it's literally
word-for-word
freshly born font it's like you were
just born again trying to find your legs
in the world like you're you're trying
to feel this place out at least from his
perspective from his perspective finding
your legs in a world that doesn't make
sense is to him making sense of a world
that doesn't make sense and learning to
live in that world and he's this is
where worse ass character development is
shown he's learned this he's learned
what Abe needs he learned what it takes
to get to the point he did it all by
himself and it took him so long Abe is
practically lucky in work - mind to have
him at this moment so he can show him
what it means
you
[Music]
before we get into that I realized it
was very quiet during that moment but
just like it's it's the same thing here
we we this is this is basically to
represent what I wanted this to look
like is it's it's like it's all this is
is it's meant to look like a VCR
rewinding cuz I just wanted this
transition to come across like something
rewinding this isn't dark applier
there's there's nothing to be gleaned
out of it when you have a VCR rewinding
especially the pre-made effect that I
just slapped on here there's some
chromatic aberration anyway that has
nothing to do with dark apply or
anything like that that's just meant to
look like a VCR rewinding and it does if
you don't think dark implies it's it
literally it looks like a VCR everyone
that's all it is so it's just rewinding
like that's all it is we're we're going
to try it again we're gonna try it again
like that's it let's let's go back to
this point and let's like try it again
from the top
[Music]
there it is yeah and then like the the
color wash the color wash is symbolic to
the gun in the holster is symbolic but
you know it's direct its he's accepting
it he's putting the gun away he's he's
he's like it's like putting your coat on
a rack you're hanging up your coat
you're you're just taking you know
you're accepting you know he puts the
gun away just to be like okay all right
and then if that wasn't hard enough just
shrug dance and when like in that moment
this is this is like the most crucial
thing of the entire stories like his
acceptance of this moment like just
shrug just like whatever like it's it's
whatever like it like this doesn't make
sense
how did we how did he get back here you
can see in his face he's all the like
when he look is there usually you can
see the questions going through his head
he's like like how did it how did I get
back here who are these people
whatever like should i arrest him like
is this should I try it again would it
end up the same way like he's like
alright well I guess yeah why don't we
dance and like this is also
[Music]
oh you like this is this is both the
credit sequence and it's also still part
of the story like they're dancing or
feeling it out there did they're just
having fun like what he needed was some
stress relief he's got it it doesn't
matter if he was shot in the heart and
it's impossible to survive that right
now it doesn't matter he's here and like
he exists in this moment and worse that
she's showing him like an opportunity
just to try something again you know
what I mean like it's it's not something
that you gotta like read into and that's
the point
it's not there it's not obscure like if
anything it's the opposite of obscure
it's it's it's very direct in in what
its meaning and that's why I'm like I'm
very happy with how this came out
like it's no it's no secret like the
surface of it is the surface of what it
is yeah
like this this video what what I
definitely didn't want at the end of
this video is for it to be tragic and
and it needs tragedy especially in this
moment when he's he's like realizing the
reality doesn't work but it doesn't need
to end tragically this is not this is
not some psycho crazy hallucination
after life like this is this is this is
the reality this is the only reality
that he has to deal with it's like this
to him to them this is reality this is
reality and this is what they got to
work with so make it work like it you
could see him like he's picking up the
dance more and more Amy you can seem
like he's picking up the dance more and
more yeah and then once Ash's [ __ ]
happy he's like alright yeah hell yeah
man
get it like live in the moment this is
it this is all you got
what's the point in asking questions
about it and then that is the end of the
series then it just gets down to BTS
stuff nothing at the end after that is
any story like sensible about it but
that's that's what it is that's what
that's what this always was and that's
what I wanted it to be and that's why
I'm so happy that it came across that
way now there that's not to say there
aren't story elements to be gleaned out
of it and there there there aren't story
elements to like be seen out of it and
there aren't there are still questions
to be raised like why did he stop at
Damian's picture and asked if he should
stop by that's a question like perfectly
valid question and just because and and
there are questions that the answer
won't be in this video they're like I do
like I did with who can market Blair the
end of it like with the radio call like
a colonel if you can hear this you
better run the question of that wasn't
answered until this video came out like
this video is the answer to that like I
I like to tie things into future stuff
that I'm going to do and if I explain it
to you then it's not going to be a
surprise you know what I mean
make sense yeah what are the masks I
don't know what you're talking about
what no one's wearing a mask I don't
know what you're talking about anyway so
yeah but like that's the point of
everything that's going on here you got
to accept the reality of it and you know
it is like that happened like this
happened this happened it's happened
no drifting off yet it happened but for
tonight you know something else can
happen that's exactly what it is so um
there's a few other like little little
tidbits that I want to show you guys
just like some breakdowns of behind the
scenes stuff going on
[Music]
if this was the hardest part about all
this is just because I had to I had to
like like I said I was directing at the
same time so Dan did a great job because
I could trust him to to get things to
work the way I wanted to work after
after like the first day I was like okay
you obviously know what you're doing you
get me now so like we can make this work
and then like I would just stop by every
once in while to watch footage and then
yeah it's just like that's so funny
you'll see in a third just being able to
like watch it having this production
crew here and just having the people
going that's very low so it was just
like it was just it was just really nice
and then you know we were able to see it
like I was able to like watch that see
what I needed you know I was able to get
what I needed out of that I bet we flub
this turn yeah I flub that turn real bad
but that's why we got in a different
shot but yeah so anyway that is the
breakdown of this stuff it was a
wonderfully fun shoot to be a part of it
was really honestly it was really fun I
am immensely proud of every part of this
this entire thing and like it's it's
just super cool to see like it's super
cool to see it's super cool to see and
it's super cool to be able to like make
these things come to life and again I I
have to thank the the sponsors who were
a part of this and the sponsors who
helped out on this because this is what
I want to do with the sponsors like I
said that I wanted like sponsors and now
it's called members so channel
membership so the sponsor button is now
a it's a join button so if you want to
help fund projects like this please
please consider sponsoring you get a ton
of perks for sponsoring you get access
to these special badges this is the
immediate badge you get a one-month
badge two month badge six month one year
and two year badges you get all these
emojis that you can see in chat if
you're a sponsor and you've got emojis
please spam it right now in chat
you get sponsor only videos at least
once a month sponsor only live streams
merch discounts community posts and
sponsor only merch then we're still
working on that but we're very close to
getting that in there but just yeah just
please if you want to help this this
this was amazing fun we did it super
quick but it wasn't it wasn't cheap it
was not cheap we we we needed like some
good stuff even if we were doing it poor
man's process and all of like the the
the corners that we could cut to make it
look what we like we wanted it to look
but not necessarily be super
over-the-top like it still cost around
40 maybe like I think it was ended up
being like $42,000 when we were said and
done with all of it like all things
considered with the the pre-production
planning the labor like this stuff like
that and that's like with me editing it
myself editing it if I wanted to do any
special effects I got to hire that out
but like these these things aren't cheap
but they're worth doing and I want to be
able to do it with you guys and I want
to be able to like make these things all
the time for you and I'm not saying this
as a pitch to be like sponsor the
channel like so I can like be greedier
and like have more like that's not why
I'm doing this at all like this and
that's why I wanted to showcase it this
specifically and and I wanted to
showcase it immediately after I told
people about the sponsorship thing and
and I wanted to like show this like this
is this is what I can do like you see
who killed markiplier and you've seen
the day with markiplier but I can't just
talk about like those things would be
like that's only the thing that we got
and that's all anything I want to do I
want to show you guys that like I can
make some really [ __ ] cool stuff and
then we can make it we can make it
happen we can make that reality stuff
happen we can make these things come out
and it doesn't just have to be like this
I can I can hire I have this idea for
one of the future videos that I want to
do we get to hire out like this
animation crew to make this cool like
not just a two minute gameplay animation
but a whole story of animation is this
like like bringing these things to life
because I love telling stories and again
this doesn't mean that normal videos are
ever gonna stop I know this past week I
have not been uploading but that's
because I was on vacation I didn't
really want to be on vacation but it was
good for my health to be on vacation but
these are the things that I want to do I
want to do all of that I want to do all
the gameplay videos I want to do like
these sketches like if I could do these
every other month I would be the
happiest man on
the face of the entire earth I would be
so happy and I can this is feasible I
edited this in three days we shot it in
three days we spent like in total of all
planning maybe a week maybe two weeks
tops
of actual planning for this thing
sourcing locations getting the crew
together finding a time when they could
do it like we can make this and honestly
like it's not that hard when you have a
good team in like you know what you're
doing and I I I'm not bragging when I
say I know what I'm doing I know it I
made this happen I had two team helping
I'm not taking all the credit for it but
I made this we made this made this
that's why and that's this is some
amazing it's just it's like the the
there's a whole world of potential out
there and like everyone's always talking
about like what's the next killer app
what's the next killer thing it's like
at the core of it all in my mind it's
always gonna come down to the the the
simple desire to share a story like it
goes back to like when we were just
around campfires and you just telling
stories like just sharing a story
whatever whatever comes out of the
imagination like it can be a great story
it can be like a funny story a silly
story like just like sharing stories and
making things and pushing the envelope
of what what what people think can be
done you know that's that's what I
really like about it and I think I think
this this is the perfect start to like
this the this chapter of of going down
this road where we can see all these
cool things and thank you so much
everybody that's sponsoring right now I
really do appreciate that and it's it's
like I can give a chance for real
[ __ ] talented people like Mick to
shine like he stole the whole show and
that's fine like at first this was gonna
be just it's called Wilfred
mother-loving Wharf sites this is not
about horses this is about Abe like he
just made it about a because it's such a
compelling character and he's told so
compellingly it's still so well uh and I
was like seeing these moments like
seeing these moments letting him come to
life like the piece of my imagination
living on screen and it's all thanks to
you guys that's just
special anyway yeah so uh now that I'm
back from vacation
it's gonna be it's gonna be work mode
I'm super excited to get back into the
swing of things regular videos are gonna
start up tomorrow and it's just gonna be
that's gonna be cool like I've told you
for a while that I was excited for the
future that's cuz I knew about this for
a while and I was waiting for so long
just be like I'm [ __ ] ready to launch
just let me out him coach stop holding
me back I turned out my light again this
is like now that's here like it's here
it's here it's happening we can do we
can take control of like the creative
process completely like YouTube was a
first step in terms of making what we
wanted to make but this is like to me
this is the next step this is next step
this is the next step of taking YouTube
to a level that like no one's ever seen
I you know I get excited easily but I
get excited because I can see the
potential of it I can't wait I can't
wait
so anyway I'm gonna leave it at that
thank you everybody so much for watching
and most of the music I source from
epidemics sound just like various world
tea free stuff it's amazing what you can
get nowadays with royalty free music
like I can fit super super nuanced
things in there but this is awesome so
thank you everybody for sponsoring if
you want to sponsor if you haven't
sponsored already please please consider
sponsoring hit the join button down
below it's right here
it's next to where you would be the big
red subscribe button just click on that
and just look through all that you get
I've been delivering on these things I
have been delivering on these things and
I've got some special BTS stuff just for
the sponsors that I'm gonna be uploading
if I can edit it later today I'll be
getting that but I want to make sure
that I get normal videos at first but
just I want to make it worth your while
and I think these are good rewards for
it I want to reward people and I love
having a little like a little little
like sounding board for ideas to bounce
ideas off of sometimes I had I had the
sponsors help me pick out a video title
for the the phone number video yeah but
just thank you guys please consider
sponsoring now it's called please
consider joining so please consider
joining become a member of the channel
and thanks everybody for watching if you
have any more questions about this whole
video I will not answer anymore because
I don't know if I answered any right
here but I did talk a lot about my
mindset behind it so just if you guys
want to expound upon it feel free I love
reading all the theories about it in the
various locations like so just talk
freely about it I love seeing people get
excited about these products it just
drives me and like keeps the candle
burning in my heart so thank you so much
and also send a lot of love to Tyler his
mom unfortunately has cancer he posted a
video about it on his channel I wrote a
community post about it as well so go
either to the community poster go
directly to youtube channel and find
that out or his twitter you can find it
pretty much anywhere so thank you
everybody so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]